hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the first Serbian
women's league it's a game between a 12
year old miyagilu and she's playing
against 40 year old uh Armenian
International master and the woman Grand
Master Lilith mccritchen and this is uh
a game where you you will not believe
this game this game is so good it's like
it's it's like watching uh like Paul
Murphy playing against uh uh Anderson on
a bad day or something like that it's
it's such a such a beautiful attacking
Masterpiece uh and coming from uh from a
12 year old um here it's uh it is best
for me to just show it to you and then
you guys can be the judge of that now
I'm not gonna call it any mortal or
anything it's up to you guys to decide
if you want to call that but I mean this
is uh this is why I I'm glad I have this
channel so let's uh check it out meowulu
has the white pieces and she opens with
Ponte E4 we have Ponte E6 McLean goes
for the uh range of Defense with D4 D5
and not Knight the C3 we have Knight to
F6 putting pressure on the E4 pawn and
Lou advances the pawn so going for the
Stein it's variation Knight after D7 and
now Queen to G4 although a popular move
in many lines of the French defense here
it is it is somewhat rare So Here pawn
to C5 uh putting pressure on White
Center as black usually does and now uh
Knight to F3 is the move that one would
play here but here we have the immediate
Knight B5 and already you can feel that
this is not something you would expect
in modern chess playing with the same
beat piece twice already going for some
Knights to D6 action we know we know
from experience that this simply cannot
be good and of course if black punishes
this correctly and of course if black
knows uh how to punish this uh the the
the the the the precise line that goes C
characters on D4 and then of course the
E5 Pawn is now hanging Ponte F4 now H5
you chase away the queen and none
Knights the C6 accident black will have
an okay game white is not lost here or
anything it's a very complicated
position but this is how you punish this
in the game however Knight the C6 was
played immediately and this levels the
playing field now white can just play a
nice game Knight the D6 with check and
again what is this move why what does
white gain here it doesn't really look
like anything and okay Bishop captures
on D6 eliminating the piece delivering
check now Queen captures on G7 attacks
the rook and h8 Rook to f8 and okay you
have to recapture on D6 e captures on D6
and now just Knight captures on D4 now
creating a massive Center here for black
and also already with the threat of
Knight captures on C2 with with a
beautiful Fork here the king and Rook
will be forked and uh it looks like you
might be interested in some some like
Bishop to D3 and of course you could
play this bishop D3 defense the pawn C4
is impossible because then you hang the
Knight however not for um she goes for
Knight to F3 and she invites night
captures on C2 now this is uh uh I'm
sure you guys are now uh probably
thinking I'm I'm tricking you into
believing that this is an actual game
that happened in 2022 but but it really
is uh Knight captures on C2 was played
which is a bad move believe it or not
here you have to realize that you are
under an incredible attack and you have
to play Knight to F5 chase away the
queen and the ones the queen moves now
you play Queen F6 you develop your
pieces you threaten Rook day trade white
has to go back and out Knight captures
on D6 and okay everything is fine it's a
nice game for both white and black in
the game Lilith played Knight captures
on C2 with check and now look at this
King to D1 attacking the Knight and okay
you already opened the door you might as
well go through it Knight captures on A1
and now uh the position is completely
winning for white but it's not clear why
it's not at all clear why so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only move that wins the game for me I
will blue while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
this congratulations you truly have the
mind of a great attacker and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Bishop to B5 look at this that is
the winning move I know it it sounds
impossible but it is and now you're
probably wondering why is this a winning
move it it does it really does nothing
other than pin this Knight but that's
all you need to win this game as it
would seem to give you to give you an
example if Ponta A6 you want to chase
away the bishop look at this bishop G5
attacks the Queen the queen has to move
once you move the queen you go after the
bishop Queen F6 there's no stopping
Checkmate it's as simple as that once
you see it of course so a little it does
not go for that she goes for Queen to B6
attacks the bishop but now again only
one winning idea and that is Rook to E1
leaving the king in the center as the
king already uh was you know breath
breath of castling privileges uh you you
have to go for that black king and now
now again can the bishop be captured
nope not at all if you play this queen
characters on B5 then comes to Rook
captures on E6 now if phone captures
Queen to E7 is Checkmate and if the if
the Rook is not captured you play King
the d8 it doesn't really matter Bishop
G5 with the check you're gonna block
Knight F6 to give the the king some
breeding room here maybe you can escape
but look at this queen captures an F6
King to D7 and now Knight the E5 is
Checkmate taking away both D7 and C6
squares from the black king So Okay
after Rook D1 can can black defend this
can Black is Black seriously just doomed
after capturing that pawn on C2 uh well
yes yes she is in in this particular
case so Queen characters on D6 is played
this Pawn really is a big nuisance here
for for the blacking so you do want to
eliminate it but this leaves your knight
on D7 pinned and now look at this bishop
to G5 the idea being that if you go for
some like A6 6. now Queen F6 the Knight
is still pinned and there is no defense
against Queen the d8 trackmate if you
could bring back the queen then you
leave control over the E7 Square then
Queen to E7 will be Checkmate so she
tries B6 and it's a great defensive
resource if uh if white is not careful
if she plays Queen to F6 now it seems
like okay you're you're winning Bishop
A6 now wins the game for black so you
have to be careful the d8 square not
covered by The Rook you cannot move your
Bishop because then the queen hangs so
black is now just winning
uh but um yeah you found finds the
absolute strongest idea and that is
Knight to E5 Knight H4 also possible but
Knight D5 does the the the job just as
well and now uh there really is no move
for black uh here yeah F6 was played uh
attacking the Knight and the bishop but
it doesn't really do all that much
Bishop captures on F6 now A6 chasing
away the bishop and now Knights the F7
attacking the queen here and it seems
like you're giving up the Knight which
you kind of are there's really no no
good way of handling this Rook captures
on F7 was played but now Queen to G8
with check and it was in this position
on move 18 that Lilith makarchan
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here Queen to G8 is not
the only winning move it's not even the
fastest winning move but it does the job
quite nicely point is that now if you
play Rook the Fate just Rook captures an
E6 uh and there's no defense you can
either give up the queen or you can play
Queen he said 7 and basically it's a
check made in three so you could decide
to maybe play Queen to f8 this is also
possible but then Rook captures an E6
with check Rook the E7 Rook captures
with check King The d8 Rook captures on
D7 opens up a discovery King 8 and now
Rook to d8 will be Checkmate as the
queen covers F7 Bishop covers E7 that's
one way to do it and even if you don't
go for this queen to G8 to check you can
even leave your king queen hanging you
could start with um
and instead of one Jade you could start
with immediate Rook captures an E6 check
the black king has no squares you have
to either capture The Rook or move the
queen but whatever you do doesn't really
matter if if you capture The Rook um
then it's only a matter of Queen to G8
check but now it's it's uh faster than
it than it was Rook The Fading Queen
captures on E6 is now Checkmate and if
you don't
um uh if you don't capture on E6 I mean
there's no movie you can play you can
play something like Rook D7 then Queen
G8 is made in one or you can block with
the queen but then we just start
capturing Rook captures on E7 and now if
Rook captures Queen captures is mate if
you go here it's the exact same
Checkmate opens up a discovery it's a
double check King 8 and now Queen
captures an F7 or Rook to d8 will be
Checkmate it doesn't really matter so
absolutely stunning game in this uh a
weird line of the French defense
um I mean it's not it's not that weird
but uh if you play the French you will
probably see the see this very often
Knight 65 Knight f87 and now usually
yeah people will go something like F4 or
Bishop to E3 but Queen to G4 in this
particular line uh can allow your
opponent to make a mistake such as this
one look at this one more time C5 Knight
B5 I mean uh people who play the French
fairly often get a position like this
but a meeting Knight B5 here as you can
see is not an easy task even for an
international master and women
Grandmaster such as Lilith mccarthan
here as she falls the victim to the uh
12 year old me I will lose uh incredible
onslaught
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said I was not
tricking you this is an actual game that
happened it's a spectacular one and I I
I'm looking forward uh to you guys
showing it to your friends as they will
also not believe it so it's I mean it's
just a masterpiece uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it we're
gonna leave it uh at the desk Queen to
G8 check because this is where it
finished so I mean uh I always I I
really don't like the French defense I
wouldn't say I hate it but I just really
don't like it and I really love it when
someone just crushes it uh so yeah yeah
very nicely done uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Jacoby more chess 960.
Martin York paparik and Sophos um uh for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's happening in the Chess
World you know
even masterpieces such such as this and
uh you know whatever is brought to my
attention whatever is suggested by you
guys so do use hashtag suggestion as I
always enjoy it uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and have
an excellent rest of your day